so since you've been to like so many
conventions right like you must have
some [ __ ] insane convention stories
oh my god i when i heard about your
guys's experience with uh that guy yeah
yeah it reminded me of the time that i
also had someone do that to us wait what
we were yeah we were in um this
wonderful convention
hall we were we were in a church they
had the panel in a church what um
yeah it was really awesome
it was really cool and uh we were and we
were doing this panel in this church i
was dressed as a [ __ ] elf perfect
yeah amazing
um and we were doing our our panel and
stuff when we're just sitting up there
and um this guy puts his hand up and he
goes oh can i give you something and it
was like quite quite a small little like
room you know like whatever and i was
like oh yeah sure sure and he goes i was
like what is it like as he was walking
towards the stage and he goes it's a
bomb
and then bolts for the stage
and literally these two giant like
security guys just went
and grabbed him and i was like
what the
[ __ ] was it actually no so they grabbed
him and he goes i'm just kidding it's
cookies
and i said i'm american
i don't think in any country no that
would
be okay
and then i think he like left and stuff
but it was just such a
it was such a like
like what are you doing buddy like what
are you doing like what do you do other
than [ __ ]
how did he plan in his head for that to
go down like what was his like he must
have been like this is going to be
hilarious like here comes the punchline
yeah no it's a bomb bomb cookies
he just got tackled before he could say
the punches
[Laughter]
ryan's got really good memory because he
he's like someone has to deal with it
i remember the one uh that you told me
ages ago of the guy who came to your
house to deliver something oh my god
there was a guy oh my i love ryan this
is yeah
this made me this story made me gay for
ryan yeah right um so this guy so we're
we're at my house it's like my old house
um and we're just chilling around and
we're with our friend jono and jonna's
like a little bro from la jolla and uh
someone knocks on the knocks on doorbell
and um there knocks on the door we open
the door and he goes this person goes i
have a package for jessica this is
jessica's house and he goes yeah and the
guy's like dressed as like a courier
yeah he goes okay and he like takes the
package he goes just to be sure this is
jessica's house right jessica nigri and
he goes yeah
yeah like i don't know and then he like
closes the door he gives us the package
and we're like what the hell was that he
was like i don't know just a guy and i
was like okay we took the package no
labels or anything on it nothing on the
labels um
i open up the package inside the package
is a
premonition
it's a story of someone saying jessica
this person is going to come into your
life and this person is going to offer
you a business deal and you are going to
take that business deal and you're going
to have the best business experience in
your entire life if you take this
business like a [ __ ] rosetta stone
what was it yeah what was this what was
this
i don't know it was it was weird and
then i was like i put it back in and i
was like what what the [ __ ] because
there was no labels on anything this was
not shipped yeah
yeah ryan
ryan knows what's up he's got like the
sixth cents for this [ __ ] yeah so he
goes what the hell was that what the
hell was that what is that and he just
gets up he goes out the door and me and
john were sitting on the couch like oh
ryan's moving ryan's on the move ryan
goes down the street tackles this guy
gets this guy in a headlock yeah and he
goes why are you here yeah like what's
going on he goes i i i bought her
address off of website i bought it like
i just wanted to give her the package
and he was like what he goes do you have
a weapon on you and he goes no no no i'm
from canada i flew from canada i just
came from the airport
what though yeah and then ryan was like
oh my god and then he puts him down he
goes don't [ __ ] move okay and the
neighbors like see him like see the
altercation and everything then the
neighbor comes out and the neighbor goes
is everything okay and he goes can you
please call the cops
like this guy can you just call the cops
and they never goes why and he goes just
please can you call the cops and the
kids like sitting on the ground or
whatever yeah the cops come
they talk to this kid and they say like
like look you can't you did you
technically can't come here you can't do
that yeah yeah yeah and like uh the cop
told ryan he's like technically i can't
do anything but i can scare him if you
want
ryan was like yes please would you like
to see his pants
i imagine they're getting tackled is
already pretty funny yeah yeah yeah
getting tackled by ryan would be [ __ ]
terrifying
um
but really hard for you
tackle me um so so then he like he like
that the cop gave him a talking to and
everything and then he like got an uber
and like walked away how old is this kid
bro this kid had been like teenagers
jeez 21 22.
down bad dude just like
so many things started running through
my mind
you bought the address online yeah yeah
you flew from canada to come down here
and do this and you came up to the door
you you could have like
just so many things just why just why
and then that's when we went okay this
is really serious like we're actually
quite like not to be like oh we're quite
popular online like we have a large
following yeah we need to start doing
something yeah so
we started like doing the whole like
internet scrub of everything like right
you do all the things to like to take
care of like your home and like your
address and everything like that yeah
don't [ __ ] do that yeah
this is that obviously uh in case we
need to spell out that is not cool you
do not do that it's worrying that there
is a website that sells addresses of
youtubers to find well that means
there's a lot of websites to do it just
because like maybe your information was
leaked by some website or something it's
right it's a database
we have a bunch of addresses yeah you
can search for a name and it'll come out
yeah
because it hasn't like the you know a
lot of countries have worked because if
you if you vote a lot of the time that's
public in a lot of countries so your
name has to be publicly registered with
an address yeah which is really
concerning yeah yeah just don't just
leave it just just leave it
i i think the the thing it was an
amaranth just recently oh that was fun
that was terrifying that is what
happened without uh
so yeah dude flew from uh estonia yeah
uh it wasn't it wasn't our editor
luckily
there are more people who live in
estonia than just one of the two one of
the superstars
oh there so yeah it flew from estonia
and was live streaming himself outside
her house like waiting like the entire
time
and like it started to gain a bit of
popularity of people watching him
because i think people were it's part of
that sick thing of like what [ __ ] up
thing is he gonna try and do yeah i'm
gonna watch yeah and uh yeah luckily uh
he got arrested uh before yeah
rightfully yeah
but like my god flying from estonia and
just and he was there for like a month
he was there for a long time waiting
outside of her house yeah yeah two done
come get your mans mood on yeah
get your man is that your bands
but like there's there and then there's
the one from uh i've got gav
yeah yeah and also obviously uh
christina grimmie uh chris
dude i just don't know
it's it's terrifying like that's another
thing that me and ryan also kind of
really considered when we were um
starting to not do conventions anymore
is because there were some moments and
some messages that we were getting too
that we were just like you know yeah i
don't think it's gonna be worth it yeah
yeah these conventions aren't going to
be taking the precautions that they need
to be taking a lot of them and i think
it's because there's a vast disconnect
of understanding of how a popular
creator online can draw such a huge
audience and become such a influential
part of a convention experience right
you know because i i saw like the video
and like everything like you guys had a
massive [ __ ] panel yeah like you guys
are about to go to anime expo it's gonna
be [ __ ] huge yeah yeah yeah no and
like i would say that like there are
times where these online creators and
like everything are have way bigger
lines and way bigger like presents than
like traditional media oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah surprises the [ __ ] out of me that
people are still not up to date with the
fact that
you guys are it's for like 10 years yeah
the convention is still kind of yeah
yeah there was a time i went to a
convention and uh i had like a huge line
and i was next to i can't i don't want
to say it wasn't it yeah yeah but he
came over to me after and he goes he
goes so what do you do like like
what are you doing what are you dressed
up as kindred like what i was dressed as
kindred from uh
and i was like oh i'm a cosplayer and i
was like all excited to tell him and he
goes oh okay
okay
oh i think there's a lot of forces at
play right like there's a lot of like
traditional agents putting pressure on
the khan to be like yeah these are the
people yeah you give a [ __ ] about
exactly and you've got like your team's
like oh we got like this cosplayer like
yeah you like the and then the
conventions i think but we got the guy
who plays an extra in star wars yeah why
are you pampering him up yeah
yeah i mean i guess we're just starting
to experience this now i mean like i
think like mcm we've talked about this
before but mcm was like a real
eye-opener for us yeah in terms of what
we need for like our convention
experience we've been to conventions
before just as our own stuff but like it
was
not even close to the same level
how cool though like yeah
it's evil parts exciting as it is scary
yes yeah yeah yeah what do you guys
think you're gonna do going forward or
what do you think you would like suggest
say if there's a convention watching and
they're like
what would you suggest
proper security give us security mail-in
stop looking down on youtubers